hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I am ready to get
back into this I thought I thought that
this was gonna be the end of the game
but apparently that was wrong so very
wrong okay so Lydia's dead and blah blah
blah don't care
gotta go to Dragon reach I'm gonna stop
here to sell some goodies and maybe get
some other goodies I have no idea I
don't know where I can buy better gear
like we're way past the point where I
played the game too so I have no idea I
don't think I've ever had anything past
steel armor hello lady I don't claim
yeah almost well yeah that's nice shut
up and take my [ __ ] um Oh Lydia had all
that crap but he had all of that crap
okay that can go uh ahead all my crap
dang it okay I need to smash that stuff
into goodies horsehide that's from my
dead horse after it died I skinned it
and took it spell with me so that I'd
always have a piece of him with me
always
okay enough crazy now you never get
enough crazy shut up lady I need to get
some leather out of this crap yes yes
yes enter enter good it's good I'm
pressing enter okay whatever leather
strips okay that'll do and I'm done I
use a blacksmith to make
a cast-iron cooking pot really really I
can I can make that out whatever done
man um iron dagger yup yup yup
Nikes don't have enough look at this
smelter miss aha you can make three of
them at a time
I should holy crap I should definitely
pick up more than that it's just yes he
sees this okay blah blah blah done like
more like more the reason I didn't make
no na boots the reason I need to make
more is so that I can uncreate so that I
can improve my armor better braces done
done done got done okay now that that's
out of the way you move on lady you're
you're in oh no wait no you're not
you're okay lady oh you are more than
okay you're fine ah good thing I have
the dwarves alone ah still just fine
fine whatever whatever yeah sure why not
alright get out of my way you're so
useless he's a steward wait I didn't
check what you had to sell got some
pieces out looking to protect yourself
Oh deal some damage you know
Oh interesting
so that's how you feel soul gems I
thought it was a spell but you got an
enchanted weapon with it or maybe it's
the other way around I don't know either
way that that's nice
that's really nice that's really nice I
want that here you can take this crappy
dwarven great sword it gives a [ __ ]
about that give me this axe my leaving
and I'll improve it - uh what what what
what what can't Oh bollocks
baloney either way it's still nice there
we go thank you
oh I got my axe okay top what are we
doing I don't get out of my ways
what did you say oh don't make me boss
Sigurd I will oh you said about your
monkey here Wow
Oh dragon rend whoops rubella for don't
care guru Bellator Han I got a check to
see what the armor is if cuz if they're
selling dwarven weapons I might have no
war in the armor welcome to war
take a look uh huh that's nice and no no
crap okay [ __ ] is this Jim wait did I
check the armor on this leg I'm just
running in circles I'm not making any
progress at all hope you guys don't mind
they don't claim I helped my father and
looking to protect yourself or deal some
damage okay you don't have it either
you're just turn you can check inside
ah that's something I'm supposed to
deliver your hands only
I'd better get going okay who think all
the council my father provides below is
his alone that's something I'm supposed
to do it I've been lookin fly advice
I've been looking for you okay
got something I'm supposed to deliver
your hands only okay
I've been looking for you got something
I'm supposed to deliver your hands only
okay I've been looking for you got
something I'm still there oh don't care
about a green apple
just [ __ ] after me guard ah
guard guard right there please Gavin
please please he's ah ah no don't kill
me don't kill me well oh god I've killed
dragon power I'm so scared of you Oh
what do you want what do you want huh
okay okay whoa I've been looking for you
that's something I'm supposed to deliver
your hands only I've been looking for
you hmm got something I'm supposed to
deliver your hands only he's got such
beady white eyes got something I'm
supposed to deliver your hands whoo okay
bye it's that curry oh it's that zombie
courier I found on the road oh oh
creepiest thing ever
anyway what is it that you need
oh okay yeah no biggie I must have
misheard I thought you asked me to help
you trap a dragon in my path yeah death
boy you know I wouldn't ask if it wasn't
important sorry but I can't do it
we'll just have to keep fighting the
dragons as best we can screw you
according to let ah they say luminix was
the Dragons name-o what that's what
skull how could I thing the main hall
what what you're asking do you want me
to let it drag ah ha part of my city yes
with the threat of war on my doorstep
absolutely there must be in other ways
grow you risk it's too great what would
you know about it all do it yeah were
liter himself oh but how can we fight
him doesn't his return mean it's the end
time well then you might as well keep
fighting I'm the Dragonborn I don't know
about such things but I heard the
graybeard summon you that's good enough
for me that's good enough
what's this nonsense about trapping a
dragon in my palace I want to help you
dragon boar and I will but I need your
help first of course now so form in
general Tullius are both just waiting
for me to make a wrong move uh-huh do
you think they will sit idle while the
dragon is slaughtering my men and
burning my city yes
No I don't care I can't risk weakening
the city while we are under the threat
of enemy attack uh-huh sorry [ __ ] your
face then I would be glad to help you
with your mother dragon trapping scheme
run both sides to agree to a truce will
be difficult at this point ah the
bitterness has gone too deep mmm maybe
what are the Greybeards they are
respected by all nor you are high
Hrothgar is neutral territory
yah Rea beards were willing to host a
peace Council
then maybe African Tully's would have to
listen pal who knocks leave that to me i
Dragonborn maybe you can stop the
dragons and this war into the bargain
yeah I got a do everything for you Oh
were you looking at oh nevermind you
never never mind never mind
oh god I hope that guy isn't waiting for
me out there I'm the commander of the
guard oh so don't care
golly why do these people think I care
about them at all my boys ah you see
don't you worry okay courier seems to be
gone courier from hell
okay alright so I go back to high
Hrothgar I'm just an errand boy go here
go there go here go there kill this kill
that ah man and now Lydia's gone and my
horse alone it's okay it's alright I'm
fine but whatever you owe your wolf car
you're not Aaron
master ah all right hello
we heard the dragon Ren shout from here
who defeated him well ah here's as much
I thought it was him we saw we are not
worries at up
what is overlooked in the Dragonborn is
not permitted to any other followers of
the way then what's the point what do
you do with your incredible voice powers
the Greybeards have never involved
themselves in political affairs shut up
do it I see the Dragon will lead you to
Potter next has made the decision to
help you yes this is the road we have to
walk yes even the grey bears must bend
to the winds of change you see him yes
so be it tell or freaking obvious that
the great beers wish to speak to them I
gotta go back and forth and back and
forth
hey we have felt the whisper I would
give me your map and I will show you
where its echo can be found interesting
hmm okay anyway
alright sky above voice oh shut up
alright you all you moved
don't make me old man I'm not afraid to
fight an old man
okay now I got a run errand boy again
oh hold on gah safe oh god no already
good ooh weird they're up oh did I go
yes
easy ah yeah hermaeus mora's the Daedric
Prince of fate knowledge and memory in
his rare dealings with mortals he often
chooses to appear as a grotesque mass of
tentacles his holy noodle eNOS I've been
touched by his noodly appendage may his
sauce ever rain down upon you - Purdy
you got it ah Oh something I'm supposed
to deliver all right now hands only hmm
a note from someone named Kyle sell no
and Markarth looks like that's it
got to go
okay that's nice
hello but that's not you that's that's
wrong that's so wrong
where's this nope what where's his note
oh let her from cup not that one forget
you got a baby get up no I'm not gonna
change my you I don't even suggest it uh
yes no mine
screw you
gamma wait late boom oh sorry so fun
alright let's see this yarol whatever
don't care about him go maybe shout oh
wait no isn't this a guy this is Ulfric
right this is the guy at the beginning
he can use the voice come here where
you're not wanted huh eat our food you
pollute our city with a stink and you
refuse to help the storm cope but we
haven't taken a side because it's not
our fight yeah hey maybe the reason
these grey skins don't help in the war
because they're Imperial spine Oh what
Imperial spies you can't be serious yeah
maybe we'll pay you a visit tonight
little spy we got ways of finding out
what you really are yeah no not on my
time oh hello do you hate the dark no
you here to us and tell us to leave no
you've come to the wrong city then when
comes and hatred prejudice and narrow
thinking unworthy of one such as I know
I know nothing new there most of the
Nords living in windhelm don't care much
for us uh-huh but Rahl is the worst
place you want me to take him for you
bears to get drunk and walk around the
grapes or - yeah
insults at us in the small hours the
morning who are real charmer that I'm a
real charmer baby some of these note and
it isn't just the dark elves thing they
make a target about that yeah in fact
just about anyone who isn't know now
it's personal I was gonna help you baby
because you so fine oh I love watching
you walk away alright so now I gotta
Myrtle eyes these people because they
all hate argonians which is Chuck oh
wait women just both craps huh spare a
coin yeah oh thank you there you go
divine boom your kind heart the Divine's
true dad what was that about training
and pickpocketing oh man doesn't it cost
a lot more money to pickpocket wouldn't
have been better off if I got training
instead here we go Baga
palace Hood Kings will give us a
straight answer he's a true Nord he'll
come around
don't be so sure of that the story
because I'm not really cross on land
everyone's talking him fight is putting
a great deal of pressure on the white
run uh-huh and what would you have me do
if he's not with us he's against us oh
don't make me don't fist we all know
that dumb head how long are you going to
not much of a strategist you think oh
shut up Joe leave I don't care I must
sit in your chair Lina sword uh uh oh
yeah my throne now home state don't you
think so we're ready to start this okay
understand
soon I still say you shall take them all
out like you did dead King horik talking
for a message to the other yars whoever
we replace them with will need the
support of our arm haha we're ready with
you I'm ready to kick your ass
I shut up on my turn to talk do I know
you I was at hello Dustin for the
chopping block if I'm not mistaken
let's see real offs alive I hope that's
true but he hasn't returned yet
oh what's on his favorite it's been
weeks in-game weeks at least I'm always
looking for able fighters not everyone
can say they made it out of hell
yep no I don't care seems we're all so
long as your criminal past stays I'm not
a criminal
through Yuna many I fear speak with ok I
have a message about time they turned
their gaze from the heavens back to our
bleeding home I have the greatest
respect for the Greybeards of course and
the dragon attacks are growing okay
someone 'less but God the horse 9 is
still delicate not all the y'alls are
fully committed to supporting me as
hiking I'm not I can't afford to appear
weak I can't agree to this
unless Tully us himself will be there
I'll tics be damned
yeah I got a song and legend if that's
true well it changes the situation
doesn't know [ __ ] Julius may be forced
to talk sense in the face of such a
threat
ah huh yes I'll give Thole us one more
chance to quit Skyrim with his tail
between his legs
right okay just don't say that I with
their false Kings yay we've been
soldiers on
let it uh okay
now done taken care of not where the
heck is general Tullius
no idea would be in solitude I yes he
would be okay general Tallis I'm on my
way you have a date with destiny my
friend well you have a date with the
Greybeards it's not as appealing as
other things but it'll do whose day time
you file
hello zero observe blacksmith rider you
feeling seeing matter how many times oh
my god why is everyone asking if I feel
sick
do I look sick how could they even tell
on our adonia missing out shut up
careful shut up
oh here we go where's the guy ah hard
whatever fly he's gonna get general
Tully's hey see ya uh huh shouted him
apart sure I guess I could work why
can't I shout anyone apart and why was
it why does he even know the voice I
don't know whatever y'all Tallis I
remember you
uh-huh you were at helghan yeah speak
two legged ricca I suspect we could use
someone like you you do realize I was on
the chopping block
I see then there's nothing further to
just yes there is what do those old
hermit
why there's nothing to discuss as long
as that traitor Ulfric is in arms
against his rightful emperor huh they
are getting to be a problem no joke I
wasn't sent to Skyrim to fight dragons
but here you are right now mr. quell
this rebellion and I intend to do just
that dragons or no dragons right I'll be
the judge Oscar yell sides by all
reports the Stormcloaks are suffering
just as much as we oh I don't have time
fair enough we're driving the
Stormcloaks back well enough at them
that's what comes Oh hair handful of
legions if the amber would yes yeah I
was fine I'll come to this graybeard
counseling okay we're all finger
planning in a town Whiterun he'd be
insane to try he doesn't have the man
okay don't care that's not what my Scout
I would all fridge attack why why is
everyone just attacking everyone why why
Civil War why give peace a chance of
cool the peace counselor oh don't care
you believe it on fix don't cloak and
generate awliyas have agreed to go yeah
I negotiated it how did you hear about
it already
whatever alright so peace cancel or
peace council away oh there we go
yay guy we're gonna have peace peace and
prosperity Oh horrible
these are prosperity alright now that
I've been errand boy hello so you've
done it huh huh men of violence are
gathered here house them in these halls
whose very stones are dedicated to peace
ha ha I should not have agreed to host
this come I shut up the Greybeards have
no business involving ourselves don't go
back on your word man
peace I'll get them I doubt it
they may put their weapons down for a
moment but only to gather strength for
the next bloodletting yeah get tired of
war far from it you know the ancient
nord word for war season amen that's two
words
so it has proved but regrets are
pointless
here we are yes doc ha gang seat at the
council table
let us see what wisdom we can find among
these warriors of scary
okay works for me
where is this where where where where
where am i over here no they're here no
here hello man you guys got here quick
get out of my way general fat ass
alright I get the mainsheet being the
Dragonborn right Oh scared now y'all
scared y'all scared
Martha Thalmor here fella scared yet
okay here we go
don't boom
bring me some ale
these people are all these people I
don't even know I don't even care they
better get this done in six minutes
hello take yours now that everyone is
here please take your seats uh we can
begin right
oh that's yarol Ulfric I hope that we
have all come here in the spirit you
insult us by bringing her to this
negotiation your chief talos hunter that
didn't take long
yeah I'm here here sure I have every
right to be at this negotiation I need
to ensure that nothing is agreed to here
that violates the terms of the white
gold Concorde hat she's part of the
Imperial delegation you can't dictate
who I bring to this council right please
if we have to negotiate the terms of the
negotiation hey we'll never get anywhere
yeah perhaps this would be a good time
to get the dragon bones input on this
yes but he's nice beard the nerve of
those Imperial bastards they don't care
think that I would sit down the same
table of that found more [ __ ] either
she walked there more [ __ ] yeah they're
more [ __ ] what's the harm
she's so fan
lettuce day maybe so but bringing her
here is a deliberate provocation
Talia's needs to know I won't be pushed
around it feels like I'm damn straight
sit down just sit down
is to observe nothing more we are not
negotiating with her is that clear Oh
Frick why so hosta
uh-huh oh wait no that's that's all
Frick that's your old bull rush she's
supposed to be on our side you know
exactly you know not this time
now that that's settled may we proceed
yes what do you do better sit down old
manners here we go [ __ ] up the only
reason I agreed to attend this council
was to deal with a dragon menace yes
there's nothing else to talk about
unless the Empire's finally ready to
renounce its unjust claim to rule over
the free people of skyrim right I knew
he wouldn't we're here to arrange our
temporary truce to allow the Dragonborn
here to deal with a dragon okay fine
with me consider even talking to the
Empire a generous gesture
are you done did you just come here to
make speeches or can we get down to this
yeah yes let's get this over with
are we ready to proceed I was ready a
long time ago
who's got take forever Frick general
Tullius this council is unprecedented we
are gathered here at the Dragonborns
request damn straight I ask that you all
respect the spirit of high Hrothgar
do your best to begin the process of
achieving a lasting peace in Skyrim yeah
I don't care about that let me kill
dragons no negotiation me yes let's get
down to it me we want control of Markov
that's our price for agreeing to a truce
so that's why you're here
you dare to insult the Greybeards by
using this counsel to advance your own
position yah relative ja this is
outrageous you can't be taking this
demand seriously I thought we were here
to discuss a truth Ellis if I said I'd
handle it
yeah Ulfric you can't seriously expect
us to give up Markarth at the
negotiating table you hope to gain in
council what you've been unable to take
in battle is that it
I'm sure y'all Ulfric does not expect
something for nothing
yes that being tired would the Empire
want in return
wait general you don't intend to just
hand over Markarth to that tweeter who
are you anyways y'all know me that I
repays us for our loyalty yes enough
first let's be clear this council wasn't
my idea I think it's a waste of time you
are a traitor to the Empire and deserve
a traitor's death rights that's a great
way to go least we'll negotiate in good
faith since we're all here at your
request yeah I'd like to hear what you
think mark Arthur's worth oh it's worth
dick deadly to me winterhold
now I need winner hold dona is a wonder
old Rifton ah I don't care I don't care
I don't care hmm the rift would help
secure our communications with seer Adil
and threatened Ulfric southern flank
you heard the man Ulfric we've made you
affair okay
are you serious about these talks or are
you just here to pause you've got up so
I expected better from you dragon boy I
came here in good faith what now it
seems you healthy grow you as for You
general Tallis I see now that Gama was
right
talking to the Empire's just as useless
as ever if you think you can hold mark
I've you as deluded as your Emperor when
you signed away our freedom for the
Thalmor Skyrim will never again bow to
your false and what did I do
let's go gamma I should have listened to
you in the first what did I do always
were a fool elfric you're no better at
diplomacy than you are in the
battlefield stop are you so blind route
danger that you can't see past your pity
disagreements here you sit arguing about
nothing while the face of the land oh it
does burn is he with you Delphine if so
I advise you to tell him to watch his
time right oh man I'm out of time ion I
advise you both I think oh god I gotta
cut it here I'll come back in in the
middle of this really long and
complicated but anyway just I got a cut
of here so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next part
bye bye